but Charlie's net worth was only a few
billion dollars and I say only as though
it's not a lot of money of course it was
but he could have made a lot more if he
so chose to but he said over and over
again that he never wanted to make money
he just desperately wanted to be
independent because it's so easy to get
caught in the race of more of just
always wanting more and never having
enough and I think the single greatest
thing that I would say I observe from
Charlie was that he knew when enough was
enough and that he' accomplished his
objective which was to be free and
independent and to just do whatever he
wanted whenever he wanted with whomever
he
wanted